good evening welcome to bismarck and
uncensored climate protesters might be
pretty irritating but the undeniably
have a serious cause you could say we
saw a bit of that yesterday when we
experienced the hottest day in british
history and recorded history anyway and
it was a surge of wildfires right across
the country causing huge damage so how
do these protesters go about winning
hearts and minds for their cause well uh
this was campaign group just stop oils
answered today activists climb gantries
on the m25 blocking and causing nine
mile bats causing of course extensive
misery for many motorists the group
first made the headlines back in march
when they stormed bafta's red carpet
then it was football's turn as they
attached themselves by the neck to goal
posts there was also disruption the
british grand prix with protesters
having to be physically dragged off the
track
in early april just up oil managed to
literally stop oil blocking tankers
around the country from delivering
petrol causing a week of shortages of
the pumps in recent weeks have seen our
guests tonight glue themselves to the
hey wayne at the national gallery and
others attached themselves to
masterpieces by van golf and turner as
well as the last supper i'm joined now
by just oil co-founder hannah hunt and
protester edmund lazarus welcome to you
both um
i suppose my reaction to this is that i
don't dispute you represent an important
cause never have done i believe in
climate change i think it's serious i
think we've seen the impact of that all
through europe at the moment in a pretty
dramatic manner i guess my problem is
the way you're going about this because
i'm not sure you're winning hearts and
minds i think you're actually having the
opposite effect and that's my problem
with it i think the kind of
cultural
wanton damage i think you know hijacking
sporting events i think the motorway
stuff we are causing huge disruption to
so many people
it's i think annoying a lot of people
more than it's bringing them to you what
do you say
i mean
so please if you agree that there's this
huge issue right now
then
you might also agree that no new oil and
gas licenses which is what we're asking
for is a no-brainer it's in line with
what the international energy agency the
ipcc the un are all asking it's in line
with the government net zero targets
right so that's what we're asking it's a
no-brainer no-brainer demand and we have
to do whatever we can to force the
government to to implement this because
otherwise we're on
um a course bound for you know more
summers like what we're seeing this week
right i mean hannah i'm not
the government doesn't seem to be paying
much attention to you guys attaching
yourself to paintings or disrupting
sporting events or disrupting motorists
going about their business some to very
important things
i mean the government aren't paying
attention to us and nor are they paying
attention to the severity of the climate
crisis i mean this week in the hottest
week of weather we've seen in british
history on monday the our uk judiciary
ruled that the government's net zero
plans for 2050 are unlawful so the real
true criminals here are our government
they don't care about the situation or
the severity of talkers but do you care
about the disruption you cause ordinary
people who've got nothing to do with
this who are trying to go about their
lives their their business
and
you're disrupting them you're you're
causing them a lot of misery do you care
about them
i mean have you seen the disruption that
the the heat waves the the fires are
literally engulfing houses in london
have you seen the strains at nhs they
are on a black level alert have you seen
the strain to our uh fire service
they've had the greatest yeah
i'm asking you though about the
disruption you cause ordinary people who
might well support the general cause
you're representing but don't understand
why you want to cause them
so much distress do you understand the
distress you're causing some people so
my personal view might just you know
you're asking me about my distress i
don't know i'm asking you for that
other people are you aware of quite the
scale of the kind of distress you cause
when for example you bring motorways
crashing to a halt
there may be people
there may be people who are actually
trying to get to incredibly important
things do you care about them
yes come on look at the situation we're
in the right
you
that wasn't the question you know with
respect to both of you i've said i agree
with the with the cause you're fighting
for
it's the methodology i have a problem
with and i just wonder whether you have
understood but you keep throughout all
these interviews that you and other
members of the media have with people
you keep throwing out this methodology
thing but if you look i just asked you
whether you care about the distress you
cause people listen we care about any
distress that is caused to anyone that's
what we're trying to prevent in doing
this because if we don't stop the
government opening the 40 new oil and
gas fields that they have planned then
the amount of distress and suffering and
death that is coming is unimaginable to
some people's
misery is worth
preventing other misery is that the
calculation you've made
yes you're just coming in with these
questions again and again
you know you're gonna get the same
answers from any of them i'm not why
don't we i'm asking you actually i'm
asking you a very specific question
because i have another guest here
uh amanda bishop amanda good evening to
you good evening where have you come
from today i've come from my mother's
funeral today your mother's funeral my
first of all my deepest condolences
thank you to you and your family on the
loss of your mother obviously
a hugely important day for your family
hugely uh and you wanted to give your
mom a great send-off and give her the
funeral she deserves how old was she if
you don't mommy ask me she was 90 she
died on her 90th birthday so she had an
extraordinary life which you wanted to
pay proper tribute to today and we all
did and what happened
we basically got stuck in traffic
because of the protests um
illegal protests from what i can gather
because unfortunately my mother lived
very close to the m25 and that's where
the hearse left from
and as a consequence we were so delayed
in traffic that we were actually um we
actually missed our allocated stuff
seeing the pictures here of the car
behind the hearse showing the host stuck
in traffic and as a consequence you
missed your slot we missed how long in
the end was your mother's funeral a very
very quick 10 minutes and my mother was
a meticulous time keeper meticulous and
i understand her best friend couldn't
even get there couldn't even get there
and it caused an enormous amount of
issues for us because not least because
we didn't feel that we could pay her the
tribute that we wanted in the time that
we did
but we had
all the other arrangements that we had
for the rest of the day were really put
out i mean
i understand why young people are
concerned about climate change i
understand why they want to protest and
so on i don't understand some of these
methods they're using i don't think they
understand the implications
and the consequences of what they do and
i think you just perfectly explained one
scenario which has been repeated i
suspect many times over today yes how do
you feel about it when you when you see
the protesters here and they
they respond the way they do how do you
feel okay well i i'd really like i i
hope i would
give as balance to view as i can because
we understand that climate change is a
is a pressing issue
um
but i think to to do the things that you
did and to endanger in forgetting all
the delays that happened to people today
actually we got on with our day
you did not disrupt our day at all you
disrupted it but we still felt that we
managed to pay a tribute that we wanted
to to her and i'm sure every other
driver and everybody else you
inconvenienced today felt the same thing
but if i was married to one of those
police officers whose lives you were
endangering today
i would be less impressed with that
particularly when i can see a tweet from
you that you're very
happy with all the firefighters risking
their lives yesterday and in admiration
of them but on the same token you're
allowing
police officers
and some people i'm sure would have said
you should be able to protest illegally
like that and just someone should have
just left you there
and
why should we all get disrupted if you
are knowing that you are breaking the
law okay what's your response firstly i
just want to say i truly am sorry for
disrupting your day and
um also condolences i'm i really am
sorry um
i want to try and look at the bigger
picture here and
the criminals
are our government they're investing in
new oil and these 40 new licenses that
they plan to open by 2025 is a is a
death project and they are failing to
protect
the people of this country which is
their fundamental responsibility what
can i just say and i hear what you're
saying and i have three young children
of my own young adults
and i also understand that actually what
you're trying to do when you make change
is actually build and bring people with
you and it's a skill to have a really
big skill and if you don't have that
skill it's either easy to do the things
that you're doing to try and get some
short tactics but actually you're not
bringing about change and even though
you might think that the governments are
the criminals i at least elected them
and if i don't like them i can elect
them again either to not be in empower
or choose somebody else i didn't elect
you and i don't necessarily agree with
your politics i mean pierce has
eleven-year-old daughter you have older
daughter and she has voices right now
she cannot elect um someone in power to
choose what her future looks like and
her future by the time it's she is my
age there will be drought there will be
food shortages and worse summers than
this one so unfortunately it's the
people we have to act who cannot vote to
elect robert okay but look i mean look
here you have
a woman who's tried to say goodbye to
her mum who's 90 years old
it would be the most important day
potentially you've ever had in your life
yes
and ends up with 10 minutes
a funeral lasting 10 minutes
for her mother
and that's directly because of the stop
the oil protest which shut down the
motorway
the best friend of her mother couldn't
even get there to say goodbye to her a
great friend
do you feel any sense of remorse about
that when you hear it i mean listen
firstly my deepest condolences as well
i think the problem is here is you as
talking about uh electing and
re-electing governments but we don't
have the time for that so if we're
talking about the net zero targets that
the government have put in place which
the judiciary have just ruled unlawful
that's in 28 years time and our country
is burning okay we've literally seen
that this week we've seen people die
because of the heat and it's just going
to get worse the whole of europe is
burning and is on fire and there are
ways to make that point there are ways
to make that point what we have
generated
determining how many people are going to
die and suffer over the coming decades
we're going to talk we're talking about
you know what kind of a future your
children your children would you replace
would you write about government don't
care okay i mean how draconian would you
be would you cut the oil off right now
what we're saying is no new oil and gas
so by the way if it was done would you
cut it off right now no that would be
total chaos but by the government's own
reports we have eight years of oil and
gas reserves left that's plenty of time
to transition away from that into
something that's sustainable and that
actually gives our generation a future i
mean we're already seeing the impacts
this isn't something that's going to
happen in 10 20. i think remember do you
really think members of the public are
going to listen in any way shape or form
to you
when you do the accident that you do and
you're breaking the law
so how how can you give any any advice
that's compelling or build an argument
and bring people into that argument and
try and persuade them when you're
actually going about this is the point
you see i looked at all the reaction
right on the news stories on all the
websites i looked at the social media
reaction
it was almost universally hostile
towards what you're doing not to the
cause you represent but to the methods
you're using it was relentless hostility
you weren't bringing hearts and minds
you were actually driving them away and
that's my problem i don't think what
you're doing is working i think it's
having the opposite affair it's getting
you short-term publicity it's getting on
shows like this
but when people hear this kind of story
they're like who the hell are you guys
frankly
to be stopping this lady from going to
pay proper tribute to her mother
to holding up a hearse on the way to a
funeral so they miss their slot who are
you to do that
you're deciding what you think is more
important whose lives you think are more
important and i say to you i say to you
i i i'm with you about the calls but
people when i hear talking about the
lives of every future generation on this
planet yeah what is more important than
every single i think every life is as
important right exactly
including amanda's mother and we risk
losing all of that
all of it every life
on this planet where does your where
does your disruptive tactics stop and
what you're going to keep gluing
yourself to things and stopping sporting
events and
lying in motor in motorists
where do you go with this do you get
ever more extreme do you get ever more
disruptive and what do you hope to
achieve with it because at the moment
i'm not saying anything
i mean listen until the government make
a statement that they won't invest in
new orleans gas projects then we will
continue to cause the disruption because
that's what history has proven can
create the societal change at the speed
and scale required some people would
argue that's a
a form of terrorism you are trying to
intimidate the problem the suffragettes
look at the civil rights totally
different it's not that is the total the
substance
the suffragettes were able to build that
move it was a movement you were so right
it was a movement of people and it had a
huge great amount of support for it over
and over
if you think people supported the
suffragettes at the time you're wrong
people hated the suffragettes like
people hated the civil rights
but they'd still managed to make changes
over time and if somebody did go down
with their ship like emily davidson at
least somebody she did that she did that
i don't necessarily agree with what she
did but she did it what i object to is
you risking the lives of everybody else
i think a lot of people feel that way i
mean how far do you take your personal
accountability for example your social
media i'm told is full of pictures of
you in far-flung places having great
holidays i presume you didn't swim there
so you're taking a lot of planes are you
i mean i i uh i thought you might bring
this up we're showing some of the
pictures here i mean this is you in hot
spots around the world which i assume
you've yes i was a child there i'm 16.
do you not find anymore i'm i'm 23. i do
not when was your last flight
i mean that there there was a photo from
when i was 16. oh that's a straight
question do you fly anymore or not no i
don't fly anymore
i truly believe that when you you know
the information and then then you can
act as a moral duty if we know this
information to determine what the future
of humanity is going to look like and
that is push for no need part of the
problem again with the debate is you
hear a lot of high-profile celebrities
and they say climate change carbon
footprint environment you know meghan
markle and prince harry two great
examples and they constantly use private
planes we've seen kylie jenner revealed
i think yesterday for using one to go
seven minutes lo there's actually a guy
now doing a website where he monitors
the use of private jets and these
hollywood guys use them literally like
caps
and i suppose the problem with that
again is if they feel
that the people preaching most about
this are doing the complete opposite
again it has the opposite effect just
annoys people peers i was a child there
and i think this shows a message that
there is no it's never too late we can
we can turn it around here we have two
to three years um
like to sort the hum the future of
humanity and
i hope that it shows that i can turn
this around in what six years since that
last fight
if there were people on the motorway
today who weren't going to a funeral but
actually were prevented from getting to
a hospital and died
would you have that on your conscience
and you're all about life preserving
life look at how many people are dying
around the world
in this it's not about that
we're talking about yeah
but look at the reality pierce the
reality is
you're a respected experienced
journalist i agree look at the reality
of what is happening it wasn't the
question why are we talking hype because
you never asked answer the question i
ask you i think you should you should be
more direct you know my question was if
there are people literally losing their
lives because you bring motorways to a
standstill and they can't get urgent
medical treatment how do you feel about
that because you're all about apparently
preserving life
and you may be costing life is that a
price worth paying for you
listen we don't want to inflict
suffering on anybody right of course but
you are you are doing that there have
been no no there's been no incidents
where that's happened to somebody so
you're talking pure hypothetically yes i
am when people are actually saying
i'm saying it's highly likely that's
going to happen if you carry on the
point and my question is what's even
more likely are you prepared to take 3.5
billion people
who are currently in danger because of
the climate crisis that's not highly
likely that's certain those 3.5 billion
people are in danger 1 billion people
are on the verge of starvation in india
you're gonna keep going right now you're
gonna keep going with these protests
yeah
and you think it's gonna bring people
around and get them on your site
it's not about bringing people around
you know people can see the terror and
the horror of what's going on right now
and people can and you know
we've actually got quite a lot of
support from these things you know after
after the hey wayne action that we did
yeah we had the school where the hey
wayne's base reaching out to us the head
teacher asking us to come
up to them doing yourselves to
masterpieces isn't going to save the
world you might think it does
but it's not going to it's just not
going to
people just go look at these idioms
they're going themselves to paintings
they don't think oh i must go and join
the galls do you know what the
suffragettes did um as part of their
tactics they slashed the rope be venus
and actually about five minutes before
we went and did that we walked in the
room next door and we looked at the
rugby venus so you're saying that these
tactics work but you're also saying that
you admire and respect what the
suffragettes have done i didn't say that
i didn't say that at all actually what i
said was i what i object to is you
comparing yourself to a movement that
might be entirely different i i am i'm
simply objecting to anybody who does any
illegal activities that endangers life
whether it's somebody who's trying to
get activity as well
what are they targeting what about
targeting china and india who are the
main polluters in the world well you
laugh but have you been over there do
you try and protest there no you don't
because you'd be locked up right so my
point is what what is the uk is like one
percent of the problem china's 33 of the
problem india massive whack of the
problem why don't you guys take your
protest to where the real this is my
problem with people like credit umber i
don't see her marching around beijing
and that would have far more effect to
me if you guys got on a plane and went
and did all this stuff and try to
disrupt china and india that would make
probably far bigger global headlines but
you won't do it because it's too
difficult what we can do is make change
in our country and other people around
the world changing our country isn't
going to change the bigger picture if
our government opens one new oil and gas
project
they've failed they've got zero targets
which we've already established around
lawful
final word to you amanda given you've
had this extremely difficult day i i
really do feel that you've got a
stronger sense of your own importance
and your own mission and rather than
you are not winning as pearce as you are
not winning hearts and minds all you're
doing is antagonizing and annoying and
breaking the law and that's something
really is the reality of it and it for
any other organization and in any other
country as pierce's we wouldn't tolerate
it and why we're doing it here i really
can't say i had a difficult day today
i've got to leave it there i'm so sorry
for what you've been through today and
my best to all your family thank you and
um you know you i'm sure even in the 10
minutes you paid your mother a great
tribute what a life she led
90 years old amazing thank you both for
coming in you know like i said at the
start i'm kind of with you ideologically
i'm just not with you about this kind of
stuff can we go and have a drink at some
point and continue this conversation i
think it's a lot bigger than this i
think the conversation is important
conversation is important we both really
loved it we'd like to engage all right
good to see you both thank you very much